this is a philosophy reflection
which is actually a follow-up to my most
recent one which had to do with the
revelations about facebook and their
experiments with emotional contagion if
you remember the news broke oh it's
about a month ago
that facebook had carried out a study in
which
some users a very very small percentage
of users were experimented on without
getting informed consent from them and
the way the experiment ran was
in half of the people's feeds they were
given
more negative information coming in
that is facebook had used some sort of
decision procedure to figure out what
kind of was negative what counted as
positive post and they muted the
positive posts so that people would be
getting a bigger dose of negativity you
could say and then for the other half of
the the well there were actual control
groups as well
for the other experiments what they did
is they
gave them
a higher dose of positive posts in some
cases muting all the negative posts and
then they watch to see what these people
in their turn would post would they post
more
positive posts on their own part more
negative posts would they be unaffected
by it entirely
and so what facebook found out was
they were affected by it but it was
pretty marginal they carried this out of
a week
what was interesting was how strong the
reaction the emotional reaction
to the revelations of this work and i
wanted to think a bit about um
are these on track are they off track
and since i have this great location to
shoot in i thought that you know
got the speaker death star here
exemplifying technology and a high-tech
incubator i would follow up and begin
talking about some of these
facebook revelations
and discuss in detail three main things
that i left as
interesting points to follow up the
question about the irb or ethics board
the issue of why are we so upset about
this
and then
one of the other questions which is
is this research itself
well founded can we in fact do research
of this sort
about emotions just using tag phrases or
algorithms focused on vocabulary
so let's talk first about the very ideas
behind this kind of study there's a lot
of research that has been going on
for quite some time into thinking about
how we could
understand
and manipulate and modify and provoke
and dampen people's emotions
this is not something new aristotle
actually discusses the importance of
this for the speaker in his art of
rhetoric
and he faults the previous
rhetoricians the technology
interestingly enough for him giving
attention only to provoking and
and dampening emotional responses and
not paying attention to the
deeper dimensions of human being of
logos and called ethos
that could produce greater persuasion
but he also had great attention to how
the emotions themselves work he made
some great contributions for example to
our understanding of how anger works
now let's fast forward to the present
where
facebook is attempting to
try to
categorize
people's posts as either negative or
positive so let's think about this for a
moment negative and positive emotions is
that
too broad of a conception to
successfully apply
where are the dividing lines there are
different ways of deciding what counts
as a negative emotion what counts as a
positive emotion there are some that are
very easy to place in that that
category you know fear anger those are
viewed as negative anxiety
um
it's not just emotion though that they
were looking for words that would
somehow signify those things it's any
sort of negatively valorous thing
bad some sort of complaint would be a
negative word then on the other hand you
have you know the whole realm of the
positive and that's a little loosey
juicy as well that's just as hard to get
a handle on and say exactly where the
dividing lines are exactly what it
consists of so you know of course words
like happy glad
joyful blissful those would be easy to
do but how do you in fact parse out the
things that fall into the great
borderline categories that's one problem
another major problem with this kind of
research if they're going to take
natural human language and then they're
going to analyze large swaths of it
facebook isn't the only people trying to
do this you know there are market people
trying to do this so that they can
predict market uh trends the military is
very interested in this sort of thing so
a lot of other
institutions as well
the problem is
human language by itself
is not so simple
as just a bunch of input outputs
it's self-referential
we can use it in ironic ways in
sarcastic ways we can be quoting
somebody if i
replicate somebody else's post in
facebook you know that doesn't happen
quite so often but think about twitter
and re-tweeting somebody else's thing
the same thing happens in google plus
somebody shares something you can share
their sharing of it you have these
nested things am i endorsing am i taking
on am i expressing re-expressing their
positive or negatively valorized
emotional state
it's a good question an open question
one that really ought to be put to those
who claim any sort of scientific
basis for for this research what they
can be scientific about what they can
easily make claims about would be things
like you know how often these words
these types of words emerge the problem
is that we're dealing with questions of
meaning and when it comes to words and
meaning we're dealing with
much more than
merely what the word unit itself
signifies in most conditions
you know facebook is used for
very personal exchanges between people
and what appears to be a positively
valorized word by the methodology that
they're using in this may in fact be a
negatively evaluated or vice versa there
may be a lot of words that are
positively or negatively valorized but
are considered as neutral
because the researchers aren't able to
penetrate into that so
all of that said what that goes to to
show us is that
we really ought to be very skeptical
about the claims made by this sort of
research
what's interesting
the research doesn't have to actually
be
on track
viable
significantly predictive
revelatory of the human condition in
order for it to be actionable
and i think that the real danger of this
sort of stuff is not that
people are actually going to be able to
predict what it is that i think or you
know what i'm going to reproduce in
facebook it's rather that they're going
to think that they are and then they're
going to make decisions based on those
projections so that itself throws more
things into the mix in many cases it's
not simply control it's the illusion of
control that produces control
a second important topic that i've been
thinking a bit about after this this
facebook
flap and after doing the first
philosophy video on that is this
question of having an irb or an ethics
board now facebook is not going to have
an irb
in part because they're not an
educational institution
and irbs generally are set up by those
an institutional review board anything
any research that has to do with human
subjects
where
you know there are certain standards a
lot to apply like informed consent
if you're going to do a study like that
then you have to put it through
an institutional review board
and they will give it a yes or no say
modify it or you need to do this you
need to do that
much of academic publishing
requires you know if they think that
you're possibly going to need an irb
they want to see your irb
so
that's the academic world and you know
kinky things go on even with that
now we get to the corporate world and
one of the reasons why the facebook
study people didn't seek out an irb is
they said well we don't need it you know
facebook gathered the information
facebook did the experiment we
university researchers merely took the
data that they generated and then you
know wrote an article on it and people
said nah that
you're all in the same bed together you
really should have done an irb for that
now
companies like facebook would not have
an institutional review board instead
what they would have is something like
an ethics board and it would perform
a lot of the same functions except it
would have broader her view
and it could extend to a lot of other
areas and this is one
you know this is going to be a
digression this is one area in modern
late capitalism life
where
things have really gone off the tracks
you know we have we have outsourced our
thinking about moral and ethical topics
and our moral and ethical reasoning to
departments like hr who are not actually
in many cases equipped to deal with that
we've
unfortunately allowed many of the
experts the people who do a lot of work
in that to be marginalized over here on
the side many of them marginalize
themselves
and we put it in the hands of people who
are not going to be particularly good
at seeing these things through or whose
whose own interests are going to steer
them to give the sort of answers that
the corporation or the researchers or
whoever it is that we ought to be
protected from is going to want and not
the answers that those who these these
standards are supposed to be protecting
think about informed consent we just
stick with that an ethics board would
have looked at this facebook experiment
and then said look you need to get
informed consent that's a good thing to
do
that
applies here you're probably violating
some people's rights
i'm surely going against some some moral
principles by doing this get some
informed consent
but that didn't happen
so maybe facebook should create an
ethics review board
and that sounds good on the surface i
can see a few issues that could arise
with that and i've written these down
for for your reflection and perhaps
spark some conversation
i think that one of the big risks
is of
putting together an award that looks
very good on paper
but is in actuality just a bunch of
rubber stampers
if you're going to pick people that are
already you
know
in prestigious corporate situations
where they do blah blah blah about an
ethics thing that is they talk the
language
that does not guarantee for you that
they actually are going to follow
through when when things start to get
sticky and ethics is always about when
things get sticky when different
interests are played there's never easy
you know ethical problems that come up
in front of you because those are the no
no-brainers it's the it's the tricky
ones
so you know the danger is that you know
whoever they put in place might not
actually provide any real scrutiny any
real oversight any real follow-up they
would probably have incentives
not to do so and it's it's i'm not
saying that this couldn't be done but
there would have to be a lot of thought
put into
how do you
create an independent board
within
the corporate structure
that's looking out not just for the good
of the shareholders not just the good of
the company itself and its corporate you
know structure corporate culture but the
good of all the other stakeholders
that's a that's that takes a lot of work
another issue is that
a lot of these companies will say things
like well you know we have these kinds
of things in place we do training in
ethics you know through hr or you know
we have an ethics board unless you're
actually making that public
and you're making it public in a way
that's accessible to the average joe who
does who's probably using your service
and
doesn't have to do an awful lot of work
to get themselves the information about
what they could in fact be subjected to
you're not being transparent their
transparency is one of those slippery
words that gets used a lot as a buzzword
but there really is something important
about the notion of transparency which
is closely related to accountability you
cannot have full accountability without
transparency because without that the
people who most need the information
can't find the information and say hey
i'm crying foul
so
would the ethics board its deliberations
would that actually be transparent would
it be publicized for instance
um would there be
discussions ahead of time hey this issue
is going to come up
does the public want to weigh in if
google if facebook actually lived up to
the sort of rhetoric that they put out
there
they would want to do that sort of thing
but you notice that they're not doing it
so that should that should give you
pause
another issue that i think could come up
in terms of the ethics board
review
you have to be very careful when you're
dealing with moral issues
not to just allow yourself to get bogged
down in technicalities and use having
technicalities as an excuse to push
things that you know are wrong
off to the side as well there's really
nothing we can do about it
and when it comes to data collection
i think that this is particularly
important
in this this particular instance
the researchers said we didn't need an
irb approval because facebook gathered
that information
and we were just using it
now imagine the reversal
there could be data that is
ethically collected you know that is
where it's being collected in some sort
of situation where some ethics born has
said yeah this is okay
this this makes sense
could that data then be
used for unethical purposes
if you had a real
robust
review process
i think that those sorts of
considerations
about what this data might be used for
not what it's just going to be used for
in this situation
but what it might be used for
would have to be part of the
deliberative process and going into
saying yes no or revise and resubmit
so the institutional review board slash
ethics board issue is not as cut and dry
as people want it to be
those are some reflections that you can
you know consider and perhaps
continue in another conversation
the third big issue that i really want
to revisit is a messier one it's not
quite so kind of dry is
were these studies actually measuring
anything real or you know what about
having an irb
it's more the open question
of how should we be looking at these
these big data social media slash
technology companies
both you know in terms of looking at
them and in terms of looking at our own
responsibilities and our own
our own attitudes as consumers
why were people
so upset
to find out that facebook essentially
did an experiment
that was poorly designed
had some
premises and some methodology that
didn't really
well they're quite shaky
and then had a very marginal result
and it worked on a very small amount of
the people involved for one week why was
this
so upsetting
well because
people think that
there's
you know things that these these
companies want to be doing and other
things that they they think they ought
not to be doing
you know a lot of people talk in terms
of privacy
i think that privacy is a bit of a
misnomer
it bothered people that emotions were
being manipulated why is that so
bothersome
when we live in an environment where our
emotions are being provoked and
manipulated all of the time
through advertising
which facebook does which google does
you know which twitter does um
why is this one thing considered to be
so egregious
well it partly because we think of our
emotions as our own as
if there's nothing else that we
get to have it's it's our emotional
states and our thoughts and if those are
subject to manipulation
in experiments not just in you know
advertising trying to get us to do
something we know that those advertisers
are trying to get us to do something but
those researchers those social networks
they shouldn't be messing with us like
that i think that a lot of people have
that that sort of point of view and it's
worth thinking about i'm not going to
say that they're right i'm not going to
say that they're wrong at this point but
i think that it's worth thinking further
about
um
i have a few reflections on this one is
that
you know there's a lack of realism on
the part of many people who use social
media
and who don't think very much about the
media and this is natural we often don't
think about you know what the
constraints what the incentives
disincentives
what the supply chain all those things
are for media and it could be a media
like a legal path and writing it could
be the printed press it could be the
newspaper it could be facebook social
media
until something emerges people tend to
treat it
for the most part as well it's just
there we just use it it's a neutral
medium it's innocuous it doesn't really
do anything maybe it's a bit of a time
waster and distracted but that's because
i have poor impulse control or time
management skills it's not a social
problem
and then something like this comes on
the scene and people start going crazy
in their reactions the reactions are
very extreme compared to what actually
went on they say i can't believe they're
doing that i'm going to get off of
facebook
somebody should do something there ought
to be a law you know the government
ought to ought to come in and take
charge of this it was a huge mistake you
know that would be the case
what i think that this points us towards
is the need
for
and i'm not sure how to do this this is
a subject for much larger conversation
the need to create an educated savvy
populous of consumers when it comes to
this sort of stuff that doesn't mean
cynics who are going to say well
whatever they want to do is okay i just
have to suck it up it's the price of
doing business whether you know commerce
or engaging in friendship emotional
postings with my
my
networks
we don't want that we do want people to
have a sense of proportion about this
and we want people to to realize that
the media
that we're talking about and these big
companies are not innocuous they're not
innocent they're not you know always
going to be on the up and up until
proven wrong you really ought to
to think about this
we need to provide people not just with
information but with the skills needed
to process to make sense of that
information about what these companies
are doing so they can make better
informed choices uh not only at the
level of whether they participate or not
but how they post whether you know to
continue with that or not
i think another thing is a different
reflection
is that these tech companies by their
very nature are a dangerous thing in
terms of information and ideology
because on the one hand
they tend to be part of this
well we're changing the world for the
better i mean that shows silicon valley
it's kind of a parody but that rhetoric
that these people have making the world
a better place these companies do in
fact espouse that google
does in fact think that don't be evil is
a significant moral
principle contentless but you know they
sort of feel well we're the people that
that are you know changing things for
the better were the if we're going to
put this in the 18th century terms were
the enlightened ones
we could be trusted
if there's anything that history has
taught us it's that
every time that somebody sets themselves
up like that they're not to be trusted
and
their limits that they place on
themselves
are not the limits that we would want
them to have in place there's nothing
really keeping these great big
tech companies and by this i mean apple
microsoft google
yahoo if they ever get their act
together
um
facebook
amazon you know
they are they are by their very nature
trying to extend themselves into every
nook and cranny they have almost
totalitarian
i might say just totalizing designs on
on things in the form of sort of a soft
despotism not a governmental one but a
corporate one
and this is just part of the environment
that we're in we should not and i'm not
saying this to get them off the hook but
we should not be so stupid as to expect
that they will self-impose the kind of
limits that we ordinary people would
like to see on
on the other hand
um
we shouldn't buy into this sort of
illusion of you know everything is happy
and nice until something goes bad so
there's two sides to this you know the
the
the corporations themselves the big tech
corporations they're not going to bring
themselves in they're going to do this
sort of stuff
and
we don't want to like you know say that
the sky is falling every time like every
time something like that happens
we do need to be savvy consumers and i
think that i'm not a great optimist
about this but the more people that we
can get to be not enlightened but
informed and have the skills to process
information the better these sorts of
big companies can be held in check
they are massive market forces there is
very little that the one person can do
against them it will take communities of
people you know crying foul and saying
this this sort of stuff shouldn't fly
so those are my reflections talked about
three different things and
there's a lot more to be said about this
i'm sure but that's where this
technosphere
reflections
are going to end